[Music]
all right welcome to chess for Knights
the class for the stronger kids oh man I
sighed you with a straight face I
couldn't okay you guys are the best at
what I'm not sure okay today we're going
to look at famous games that were played
a long time ago in a galaxy far far away
and the games will be featured in the
next Star Wars movie okay because the
director went rogue BAM
all right this is your favorite game
steinitz has white versus current Vaughn
Bardot laban no talking now this game
has a funny story because science was
the world champion for four give or take
27 years and Kurt von Bartle a band was
nobody okay actually he changed his name
to nobody after this game now this
wasn't the most famous tournament ever
Hastings 1895 it was so famous that I
went to Hastings in 1989 and got married
and in two weeks I'm getting married
again okay so I'll be married soon for
the third time third time lucky right
this is the good player is always lucky
right no hi so this tournament had
players from all over the world in 1895
did they fly there in airplanes now did
they did they drive there in their fancy
cars no most of them took boats and
trains and they walk it took a mule so
it was hard to have tournaments
because people live far away and there
was no transportation that was good but
this tournament had all the best players
in the world this tournament was 22
players and they all played each other
and there's most of them see they all
had suit and tie and canes and you know
why they had canes because they were
able good answer okay
so though that Stein it's right there
obviously some of the players weren't
there
because you're tired okay and that's the
cross-table see that that's everybody
playing everybody while the guy who's
number one right yeah Pillsbury when he
won they were like wow that takes the
cake got nothing okay
it's like I'm at home all right and then
the guy who came in fifth Steinitz
he had a white against the guy who came
in seventh and the guys who were number
three and number five
those were the world champions for 53
years okay so the guys are pretty good
okay and then export okay now I tell you
a funny story this game was played in
round 10 out of 21 rounds in the first
nine rounds the guy with black von
barda's laban he didn't lose any games
just wins and draws then he lost this
game then he didn't win any games the
rest of the tournament so I guess he
didn't like losing this game now there's
two ways to lose at 1895 you could get
checkmated or you could see I resign
you're too good he lost a third way he
was losing instead of resigning he got
up and left yeah because he he won the
good sportsmanship award later it was
changed to the Hikaru Nakamura good
sportsmanship award they changed it to
that okay yeah don't edit that out I
know you wanted we don't know talking
okay so this games a very famous game
because white sacrificed material every
move and the computers like good job
that's very interesting because
computers in 1895 were very good right
Frank Frank's like yeah okay so they
play an e for a five and opening you've
never seen before
okay and no talking if this game was
played today
for example Cara whatta kramnik which
was played today
then white would play d 3 d 3 is nothing
to sneeze at that's a good move
ok but this was in 1895 when they
sacrificed every move and
played for me so he played d4 now black
can take everything ok and d4 was the
style at the time not anymore
takes takes check and if this game was
played today probably Bishop d2 would be
playing but he played Knight c3 and if
this game was played today black would
play Knight takes e4 ok and actually
there's a lot of theory about that you
have to know everything to move 20 or 30
and I had that position once and that's
it for me I'm never doing it again black
played d5 this is based on a concept the
one o'clock class never heard of a pin
because after it takes tanks you can't
take with a knight because it's illegal
you could try to take with a knight but
the computer won't let me okay
so white didn't want to be pinned so
white castled and black unlike you guys
developed his pieces notice black
develops all of his minor pieces and
white developed most of his minor pieces
in castled there's one minor piece white
didn't develop the bishop so he
developed it also he attacked the Queen
and black retreated and now this
positions excellent for black except for
one thing he hasn't castled as soon as
black castles black has no problem
unfortunately Mike didn't Castle this
game because white went to great lengths
to stop him from castling
first everybody took everything take
steak steak steak steak steak okay
now nobody can take anything and blacks
going to castle next to move and he'll
be very happy and white played rook e1
to black castle now no because then he
loses Knight now if it was white smooth
white would play rook e5 attacking the
Queen then he played Queen e2 and rook
e1 and black would say why are you
attacking my knight so much so black
stopped white from playing rook e1 riki
5
you f6 breaking the most important rule
that's not the rule but good enough
never play f6
okay white play Queen e2 threatening
mate black didn't want to get made is he
protected his Knight okay now both sides
made a mistake but it's too hard for
this class so we'll just skip by those
rook c1 c6 the both of those moves are
bad but c6 is more bad okay now the
reason c6 is bad is black should get his
King off of he eights because he's going
to get crushed but black was like white
has no threat I'm not worried
ridiculous and white was like wow my
rooks on an open line my queen and a
wrecker on an open line I'm the greatest
and actually he was the world champion
zone but he wanted to get his knight
involved but that seems sort of
difficult because if you move your
knight to the green squares the guy
takes it and you can't take your own
pawns however we have a name for this
when you want to take your own piece but
you're not allowed to you get that piece
out of the way and we call that a
clearance sacrifice you get your piece
out of the way then you do what you want
to do I did white get his pawn out of
the way see in the land of the blind the
blind what you with the right answer
d5 BAM and black was like oh boy a free
pawn well you can't take with a knight
because the computer won't let me
because it's illegal you can't take with
the Queen because you get checkmated in
one move I deal with the pot now
remember there was a pawn there and now
there's not a pawn they're so black
White's like oh boy
Knight d4 okay now if it was White's
turn to move let's make a stupid move
for black then you play Knight f5 and
black resigns
or you could not resign and lose all
your pieces again made it also good if
you play nine tastes tonight the
computer won't let you because it's
illegal it's pinned if you take with a
queen you get checkmated and won and if
you don't take my knight I win your
night for free and crush your king
now the reason Knight f5 works is
because the Knights pinned or as you at
home are thinking knife f5 so black
unpinned his Knight how did he do that
you if he cancels which doesn't pin the
knight then you lose you're not because
attacked twice right
Oh bathrooms over there you with the
glasses King f7 right now the night's
not pinned and it's still defended okay
and white played 96 because he wants to
play rook c7 rawr and black is like rook
c7 I don't want you to do that so you
played rook c8 now if his King goes here
it looks like he castled okay and why
play queen g4 and if he plays Queen g7
that would be good for white you agree
right so black didn't want that to
happen
I wonder what plagues it about it you
he did g6 now that would be illegal so
white didn't do it now why did a double
triple its discovered attack check with
a twist I like the way several kids
raised their hand I just explained it
well for them you I just gave it away
with my description 95 now some of you
see it's Czech and some don't and some
of you see Queen takes Queen and some
down so White's checking blacks King and
whites threatening the Queen black
doesn't want to lose his King and black
doesn't want to lose his Queen but
they're both attacked so he moved one of
them away and defended the other one he
played Queen e8 defending his King
trading is while this was 1895 now he
didn't do that what did he do I'm not
sure if your hands up is your hand up
then you with the green sweater and hand
like this what did black 2
I didn't hear you but you're right King
e8 now if white takes the Queen then
black takes the Queen that's fair
okay now white played a very famous
series of moves which you'll always
remember until like you leave the class
then you'll always remember it for the
next minute okay why play the craziest
sacrifice ever but it wins immediately
so it's pretty good okay now you'll
notice White's down upon because White's
down upon number when you play d5 in
games Pond away and as a result blacks
King didn't castle too much and blacks
rook here is not so good light strokes
are pretty good okay and whites Knight
is all over the place and blacks knight
is pinned and can't move so that's
pretty good for a pawn okay now he
decided to checkmate his opponent even
in 1895 checkmating your opponent was
good you see you're always right
indicating you've seen this game never
saw it
they still always right you come from
the truth-telling contest okay rook
takes a seven Shaq okay now you'll never
guess what black did you'll never guess
I'm not even kidding you actually won't
guess what he did you know you didn't
resign he didn't take the rook at all
I'm serious he played King f8 alright
but let's let's Anna let's let's analyze
so you guys are okay if he plays King d8
then Queen takes Queens pretty good
right that's me okay
if he plays Queen takes rook then rook
takes rook check rook takes throughout
Queen takes rook check I think White's
ahead of Knight yeah you didn't want to
be behind tonight if he plays King takes
rook check the King has to defend the
Queen so he defends the Queen check has
to stop the check now it says ninety
four check which is wrong
rookie six check is probably the best
move and then whites winning here
White's up a knight a mating black and
white
also winning here Rick see one mate
would be a good move but it's illegal so
the computer won't let me do it because
it's pinned okay
now King f8 is a crazy move crazy like a
fox not like Fox News okay and blacks
thought he had all the trumps but he was
crazy new Trump I mean black
he played King f8 now all of you are
confused you're like wait a minute
he could have taken with the king and
taking with a queen he moved away so
you're all confused because you're like
old boy I don't know which way to take
this Queen but actually if we take the
Queen you lose because if you take the
Queen then I checkmate you okay and if
you take the Queen this way then I
checkmate you and if you don't take the
Queen Black is threatening Queen takes
rook Queen takes Queen rook takes rook
mate and pawn takes Knight every white
piece is attacked scary right you with
some comments later not now it's coming
but you're close Rick f7 was played okay
now black has three legal moves King e8
King g8 and Queen takes rook if Queen
takes rook rook takes rook check and
whites winning all of black's pieces
would check so that's bad if King e8
Queen takes Queen is checkmate so that's
also bad so he played King GA and then
he checked him again if King takes rook
Queen takes Queen check and black loses
all of his pieces if King f8 then Knight
h7 check and whether the King goes here
or here Queen takes Queen is check and
if Queen takes rook if queen's eggs are
crow takes rook check which move don't
say there say the move
don't see their king FA this is what I
said that you said if he goes there
don't say the heir say the move use your
words if he takes the rook alright never
mind is correct
okay so black played so black played
King h8 BAM okay now let's look at the
last few moves check here check here
check here okay then he took a check now
just like aspen black got up and left
except aspen came back so here instead
of saying i resign
great game you're the world champion he
got up and left and then what award did
he win named after whom yeah very good
that's good teamwork
very good he's like am i editing that
out alright he still doesn't know okay
that's good let's find out why he left
okay so in this position what should
black do take with white that's what you
meant
okay King GA then you check again and it
looks like you just check back and forth
except the black pawn isn't here anymore
the one that white just took so now you
play Queen h4 check it wasn't checked
before but now it is what if who don't
say what if he moves say what if black
plays the following move it would have
black does something or white ah the
lonely just looked at one minute ago
then I said this we just talked about
this remember I said now there was a
pawn anij have another wasn't okay so
King Jay check only legal move only
legal move only legal move check check
check check mate
also this black rook did a good job no
but every move black was threatening
rook takes rook mate but white always
put black in check and black made a lot
of King moves that's the
safest okay so that game was a famous
game it was one of Sciences only good
games i could show you game Steinitz
played and you're like he's the world
champion but you play better than in
usually but this game okay
White's King was very safe blacks King
was not raise urine if you have a
question don't raise your hand you look
is he won the good sportsmanship award
yeah some people don't take losing very
well like this guy I guess
but there's nothing to be mad about
white played perfect and great so that
was it's great game
sometimes you're up like five pieces and
you hang Natan one that you're like what
I was winning when that guy just got
crushed fine okay anyway he walked down
and didn't resigned the rest of the
tournament the next 11 rounds you didn't
win any games still did okay in the
tournament yeah okay no talking alright
now the last game we're going to look at
is the game itself isn't good but it's
the most famous move ever played it's
the game Levitsky Marshall now there's a
apocryphal story about this game that
when the game ended the move was so good
it is good that they threw gold on the
board okay yeah they said wow and they
just threw money okay and actually what
other people said was people were
betting on the game that was the game
ended they were paying okay I like the
other story well wow that was a great
move here's money okay alright so
Marshall played the Marshall gambit it
is called the Marshall gambit okay and
nobody plays an out is terrible
he played c5 nobody plays c5 okay and
then well yeah Marshall played the
Marshall game and named after him okay
and White's like I'm not taking anything
all right so the game was sort of boring
okay nothing was happening nothing
happening everything's equal trading
pieces boring okay
ah probably blacks better
okay Black's up upon white took the pawn
back now if you take the rug
there's Queen takes rock so it's equal
material the night attacks the Queen the
Queen has to stay pinning the pawn so he
attacked the rook this way oh okay rook
there now the pawns attacking the rock
so rookie five rock eight six all your
Queens attacked Oh Queen g5 now if I was
white I wouldn't put my free pieces here
or a knight could fork them if you know
what I mean I think you know what I mean
okay you incorrect so black played rook
takes Bishop hoping for takes and then
you fork the king and queen and rook
that's very important that's very
important okay and and black white
played the move rook c5 attacking blacks
Queen confusing everybody that's nothing
to sneeze at so this rook is hanging
this rook is attack this queen is
attacked blacks up a knight etc etc etc
now every move wins for black all normal
moves win but Marshall played the most
amazing move in chess history that's
better than the normal move okay
the move is so great that you would
apply it missing everything and still be
good
you'd be like oh we could do that I
missed that all we could do that but
it's good anyway okay so this is a good
time when ignorance is bliss right you
hear me talking over there that's a
great look perfect don't ever change
that look what's that okay now you got
peaches walking in he knows every game
ever played he knows the right move is
ya Queen g3 when you're good at chess
you know famous games you like wow I
remember that so black played the move
that makes no sense
Queen g3 okay that's a very famous move
because nobody would do that okay except
that's the greatest move ever and white
gave up okay four alright so blacks
threatening Queen H to me that would win
four black
right okay that's why you play Queens g3
he's threatening Queen age to mate all
right we have three ways to take the
Queen let's look at all three H takes G
check me that's good for black right
okay pawn takes the other pawn takes
Knight check there's a rook here so you
can't play King F to checkmate
okay and the other way to take the Queen
is Queen takes Queen Knight check Knight
takes check you can't take with this
pawn the computer won't let me take with
this pawn it's checkmate and if you play
King's you won I have two winning moves
I could check you and then move my rook
away anywhere I'm up a knight or I could
take your rook and then move my knight
away and then I'm up a knight they both
win so after Queen g3 either gets mated
no whistling he gets made it in one he
gets made it into he gets made it in
three or he's a Knights on an endgame so
he just gave up Queen g3 is a nice move
it's hard to understand how he found it
who's looking at moves like that who
looks like Queen g3 alright and then
they threw money on the board and then
what did he do ask only Aspen knows what
he did after Queen g3 no he took his
microphone off dropped it and walked out
it was the first example of that
happening 1912 the guy who was black was
the US Champion for a million years
because they didn't have tournaments
that often so his name was Frank
Marshall if you've been to New York
raise your hand
New York City not the state okay also
New York is in the u.s. which confused
one of my classes once they were like
what do you mean New York's in the US
I'm like yeah they thought I was lying
no they that's also in the u.s. yeah
they were confused like New York's in
the US what okay anyway if you go to New
York the longest chess club that's been
in New York is called the Marshall chess
club named after Marshall that guy well
I mean he was US Champion
forty years he played in all the
strongest tournaments ever he played a
World Championship match and got the
SmackDown
he played Kappa blank a cat blank it was
better than him a lot better he didn't
lose he got beat Kappa blanket took his
mic and dropped it it was terrible yeah
he was right to do it too
yeah alright so that was the most famous
move ever
Queen g3 plus tax BAM and why gave up
again so you should learn from that you
already know how to give up I've seen
you do it but now you can learn how to
play a good move solid
[Music]
you
[Music]